welcome to this video playing am joshi
from egypt and after now struggle i
managed to get back to 24 and a wife
took care improved a bit recently my
fault let's see ok let's play my age 3
line and see what we get here ok let's
consider probably night a six-night a 6g
for this is the normal way to proceed
yeah h6 is something that black can
always flick in it is some this
sometimes useful sometimes not really
really hard to tell if if i was so black
here I wouldn't play it but it's um it
has got some advantages and
disadvantages ok what I'm trying to do
is to play h5 try to provoke him to
close with g5 and I'm wondering if I
have a good timing for that he might
he's may be able to take on yeah and
then played b5 this is son this is a bit
annoying ok maybe after maybe I have g5
here and then take b5 he's very quick
here with
okay but I what saw I wonder I wonder I
wonder I could take this is sound very
very calm battle ciao okay I could do
that take care take b5 this weekend's
the docs crass enormously but turn the
only way to oh I didn't see that one at
all hmm that's bad now okay I need to
take it and maybe i can now you won't
play g5 yeah that's a very messy
position but at least I'm now you must
take a decision to take or not to take
and if he does not take there are many
yes there's something something hanging
here can take here and Bishop to h5
maybe
yeah probably this should be should be
conscious with the pre move since can
can lead to disaster okay if it takes do
I take with the queen or do I take with
rook yeah Queen takes us why this is I
didn't didn't consider at all okay if
not see for the screen before this is
this is ridiculous so I need to do
something else isn't rook do you wanna
move maybe yeah how to tell but it looks
it looks quite attractive if you should
take Queen tags i have group g6
threatened immediately
and retakes and probably long castles
all night takes that long castles looks
best ready ok I will definitely need
both looks and now I'm threatening
nights before I thought I'm attending
this okay well if I take here he is
going to play look to see a it can also
take on f5 that's that's also good
intending rook g6 or or queen g6 if
everything else fails if you place rugby
eight for example I can always play
Queen g6 to get the Queen's off we also
must reckon with tags g7 if he moves to
the Queen away from the cover of the g6
square I will sack on g7 and may tell me
let's say queen before for example again
then then Queen g6 is a direct med
however you put it I don't think black
is going to survive this unless I'm
blundering stuff
black resign yeah that is his toast here
many many threats rukan an IDF six is
the simple 195 yeah this went down and
really quickly despite my my all the
side in the opening I didn't I didn't
really want to allow be five but maybe
it is not so bad maybe it's not so bad
the computer even wants to play g5 and
then take on behalf am I didn't want to
do that at the main point is what i play
this i overlooked tonight g4 completely
I was thinking okay I'm winning upon and
giving up the dark squared bishop is
always tricky but it is not so danger
that the moment is bishop so I thought I
can't afford it but he can take here
which I overlooked it does not seem seem
to be completely bad but it's very
unclear this position I mean I'm maybe I
can take take andrew bishop you six
something if we if we exchange the light
squared Bishop so i will get c 4 and
this this looks very very dangerous for
the macula maybe you should play Bishop
age seven just keep it it's maybe better
here i'm already pretty satisfied with
my position position and here Mia may be
here I can take on a five already but
this is not bad oh the computer gives
look which is happening with plus eight
okay so let's let's consider that and
now this one in tending hook g6 I my
yeah yeah okay this is this is very very
hot would like to play if you place a
counter-attacking move I still have root
g6 this is the type of move you can
easily miss as a human yurius you think
okay I need to
do something against [ __ ] on but it's
just the paper tiger it's just just just
to sex and that's it here the king is
perfectly secure Tim that's gone he has
no way to defend it something like that
you're not going to survive and many a
mating patterns here f6 it's just just
one one win yeah pretty quick win
surprisingly okay thanks for watching